Dr. Arnn: Welcome to the 163rd commencement
exercises of Hillsdale College. My name is
Larry Arnn. We have here today the chairman
of the board, Bill Broadbeck, the vice chairman
of the board, Pat Sajak. Other members of
the board including Cleves Delp, whose daughter
is graduating today, and all of you ladies
and gentleman welcome. That was bishop and
Chaplain Peter Beckwith, and Provost David
Whalen that you just heard from. I am the
president of the college. As we meet here
today, the world is changing very fast. This
reinforces the view that changes the only
constant, that development replaces nature,
but history replaces God. Yet the ceremony
has been done 162 times before, every time
like this one.
The form of this ceremony is as old as the
first universities, in the 11th and 12th centuries.
For almost 1000 years then, people have come
here to do what we’re going to do today.
It is not accidental. It is chosen, intended,
and when we human beings choose and intend
anything serious for a long time, it is likely,
we think, that it is blessed by something
beyond history and change. We think it is
blessed by nature and by providence. We make
the claim here today, so it has been made
for 1000 years. What is the purpose of the
ceremony? There are 325 of them sitting there.
We’re going to pronounce them fit and ready
to live fully human lives in intellect and
character, as nature intended.
We think that means they are intended to be
free. Free to speak their minds. Free to worship
their maker before whom they must stand. Free
to learn the things both moral and intellectual,
that are excellent and worthy. Free to pursue
those things according to their own conscience.
Free to seek the happiness that can only be
found in these activities. Free and required
to stand up to the pleasures and the pains
that will tempt them to do what they ought
not. Free to prepare themselves when they
are young to do that. We say today, before
the day is out, that they have done that,
and present them to the world with that claim
from us.
The ceremony takes its form from this nature,
and also it takes its form from the need to
recognize everyone who has made it happen.
There are three to be recognized. Begin with
the parents of these seniors. We take great
pride here in our relationship with the parents
who send their children to us. We return them
back to them as adults. They come to us in
droves on parents’ weekend. How many are
here today? How many parents are here today?
Would you stand up for a minute please?
Do you feel completed or exhausted? We’re
more like you now than we were 4 years ago
when you showed up here, because we feel exhausted
now too by these people. Parents weekend,
our faculty, who sit there, I will say a word
about them in a minute. They take hours, twice
a year, to meet with every parent that wants
to meet with them, any parent. They tend to
be the parents of the students they have in
class, but I know they answer emails from
all of you whenever you send them. I do too.
We’re, by our preparedness to forego certain
revenues that come from Washington, DC, we’re
able to talk to you about your student more
freely than other places are. We find a partnership
with you. The word college means partnership.
These three groups that I’m naming, they
are the component parts of the partnership.
Whatever has happened that has led us to this
place today, we’ve done that together. We
want you to know that we remember that. We’re
proud of you and grateful to know you. I love
to say, and I mean it when I say it, people
always come up to me and they say, “I want
to thank you for what you’ve done for my
son and my daughter.” I always say, “Couldn’t
break them with a stick, after you’ve done
what you’ve done.” Then there are the
faculty. Four of them are retiring today.
Ellen Justice Templeton, a French teacher,
who graduated from the college, has taught
here for 44 years. Dan Sendall, not here today,
literature teacher, taught here for 30 years.
Brian Zeller, a math teacher, has taught here
for 25 years. Will Morrisey, a politics teacher,
came here the same year I did, been here 15
years.
They stand for the others, 160 of them maybe.
I can’t remember how many we have. All precious,
and think what kind of people they are. They’ve
all got 30 years of serious education. They’ve
all given their lives to know something that’s
not very ruminative to know. Then they take
all that knowledge and they’re all used,
by the way, to being the smartest people around,
in that academic way of being smart, which
means patient with the details but also able
to grasp some big thing that’s implicit
in the details. They all have minds like that.
That’s why they’re such a joy to know.
That’s why you learn. Whenever you’re
around them, you can’t help it. Then they
take these 18-year-olds, now 21-year-olds,
who show up and they give them all that. That’s
their calling. That’s their life’s work.
They take enormous satisfaction from that.
They are irreplaceable and the best thing
in the college, and I thank them.
Then the third group that have made all this
possible are of course the seniors themselves.
Human beings are the kind of thing that are
responsible for their own making. They contribute
to it. The philosopher says they hear a little
voice all the time, telling them what they
should do. Then they hear other things too.
Something threatens pain. Something promises
pleasure. Something promises an easy way.
Something promises they can have something
that really somebody else should have. They
hear both those voices all the time. What
they become depends on which one they listen
to. Most of us listen to the better one most
of the time. You know, you don’t get a serious
education when you’re 21-years-old, unless
you do it an overwhelming majority of the
time.
There’s a reason why we leave our backpacks
around here all the time and nobody steals
them. The reason is represented by these seniors
right here and now. What are they like? A
few months ago Paul Rahe, Professor Rahe, sent
Loray Ferguson to see me. I hadn’t met her
before. She’s in this class. She’s won
a national Greek translation competition.
We’re the best at Greek and Latin translation
in the world. By the way, this senior class
… Actually there aren’t that many seniors
on the women’s track team, but women’s
track team comes second in the country. The
classics competition teams in Greek and Latin,
they typically come first in the country.
It means it’s a flexible college. We have
some range in us here. Also the music is really
good here.
Loray, she’s a violinist and she’s classics
translator, and I get in this conversation
with her. She wants to talk about … She
wants to write about and learn about morality
in the classical world, and morality in the
Christian world, early Christian world. I
know a little about that because one of my
teachers wrote about that. I start talking
to her ... Somebody who has some graduate
education in those things. I can’t say anything
she hadn’t thought of. Then there’s Joshua
Benjamins, who wins national Latin competitions.
Then there’s Garrett West off to Yale. There’s
Ashley Wright off to Oxford. There’s Sam
Ryskamp, the outstanding senior man, fine
and smart. Shelly Peters, second in her family
to be the outstanding senior woman. There’s
our stinking resented valedictorian Matthew
Sullivan, who has defied me and outfoxed our
faculty, and graduated 6th in 27 years with
a 4.0.
If he weren’t shorter than I, I would have
kicked him when I saw him earlier today. Then
there’s the salutatorian, Bailey Lindner,
who is about to go off and take the accounting
exam and overcome what happened last year,
when one of the 60 best national scores on
the CPA exam was a Hillsdale College student.
She’s promised to do better than that, just
so Sullivan doesn’t get all the praise around
here. It’s a sad thing. One of the finest
young women any of us ever met, was killed
a year ago, August, in a car accident, over
by Monroe, Michigan, and would have been a
member of this class. We should remember her
for just a second today. Her name was Brittany
Aimes.
I would say to this class that I’ve never
seen someone so crowded at the top. We’re
so blessed here at Hillsdale. The kids are
smart. Things go well. They go on to very
great things. This year it’s hard to name
them all, that do something splendid in character
and mind. Their consistent excellence is a
marvel to me. I ask everybody to congratulate
them on their splendid record here.